alors écoutez il s'agit de deux
Britanniques Hayden hasling et de Sean
piner ainsi que d'un Marocain Brahim
Sadoun ils avaient été fait prisonniers
dans l'est de l'Ukraine ils ont été
condamnés à mort par un tribunal de la
république séparatiste prorus de Deniez
pour mercenaria c'est à dire qu'ils ont
été reconnus coupables d'avoir participé
au combat comme mercenaire selon
l'agence de presse rue Stas qui cite
l'avocat de l'un des trois hommes les
trois accusés ont décidé de faire appel
Shawn piner et Brahim Sadoun avait
plaidé non coupable aux accusations de
mercenaria lors du procès mais ils
avaient reconnu avoir leur participation
au combat le chef d'état-major des
armées
Ukrainiens a précisé que tous les
combattants étrangers venus combattre
l'invasion russe en Ukraine bénéficier
d'un contrat avec l'armée ukrainienne et
que s'il se faisait capturer par
l'ennemi et bien il devait être
considéré comme des prisonniers de
guerre notamment selon la de Genève le
ministère britannique des Affaires
étrangères à de son côté indiqué qu'il
travaillait avec le gouvernement
ukrainien mais aussi avec le ministère
des Affaires étrangères Ukrainiens pour
tenter de ramener ses ressortissements
Pauline dans l'est de l'Ukraine on sait
que la ville stratégique de Severo
denietz qui est le théâtre d'une
bataille acharnée entre force russe et
ukrainienne la situation est toujours
confuse
oui situation confuse et une situation
qui évolue dort en heure il y a
énormément de combats de rue dans la
ville de Severo doniesk c'est le
gouverneur de la région de louance ce
qu'il a indiqué il est impossible pour
le moment d'évacuer des civils puisque
les bombardements sont beaucoup trop peu
intense les hôpitaux ont indiqué de leur
côté avoir de quoi pour l'instant encore
soigner les blessés mais jusqu'à quand
et puis si on peut dire un mot également
de la ville de Lucie de chance la vie
qu'il se trouve juste en face de ces
verandonias et ben elle est toujours aux
mains des forces ukrainiennes mais elle
est bombardée sans relâche par les
forces russes le gouverneur de la région
de Louhans que a réclamé une nouvelle
fois aux Occidentaux des armes lourdes
de longues portées puisque selon lui
l'affirmait que si il pouvait obtenir
ses armes et bien l'Ukraine réussirait à
reprendre la ville de Severo de nesk
entre deux ou trois jours mais pour le
moment ils attendent ces armes alors les
États-Unis leur ont livré des
lance-roquettes de longues portées mais
les États-Unis ont annoncé qu’avant de
leur fournir d'autres armes comme
celle-là ils attendaient de savoir si
les soldats Ukrainiens ils en font
environ une trentaine pour maîtriser ce
genre de lance-roquette était bien formé
afin de leur pouvoir leur envoyer de
nouvelles armes